one light that definitely is uh not at
the end of the tunnel but right here is
you know
we jets fans have to we have to band
together we have to hug each other to
get through this
and joining me right now back here on
the rich eisen show is a jet and met fan
uh whose new movie uh love and monsters
is available on premium video on demand
and for digital purchase this very
friday
love and monsters is about actually
being a jet fan isn't that right dylan
o'brien is that a correct factor
bro am i am i wrong am i wrong in that
setup
that i mean that's like how i approached
it you know
um whenever i talked to my director like
you know
acting coach on set they'd uh i think
their eyes would uh
gloss over a bit because they would know
what i was saying but that's kind of how
i approach every role
[Music]
that's where you get that's where i get
the trauma that's right
that's where you dig deep about the
monster apocalypse that you're dealing
with as your character in this film as
you just think about
everything uh on the other side of the
line of scrimmage isn't that difficult
yeah we don't have to talk about the
movie at all by the way we gotta get
into it we gotta get into some stuff
we've already got three
we're already three minutes down oh
dylan o'brien how you been man you're
good life's good sir
how are you it's been too long since uh
you've been on this program i'm i'm
doing fine i am doing fine so you are
are you
you're from you're born and raised in
manhattan is that is that the drill
is that no no i was born i was born in
new york i was born in the city i grew
up
uh in union springfield uh union county
new jersey
okay and then uh and then i'm an la
hybrid i moved out to l.a when i was 12.
um but never lost my mets jets uh
and so many people like have always said
to me
uh out west or just in general at all um
like why you know why don't you just
like convert or something and i just
like
immediately sort of write them off as
even understanding like what being a fan
is because it's just that that doesn't
that's not like you know
that just doesn't make sense is that
blood you know what i mean yes it does
um uh but yeah and then uh you know
classically enough weird
i just like chose this it's like
masochistic in a way again it's very
like actory like i just choose to be
miserable i guess um but it's like i'm
also not
that's the thing though too is like i
talk about a lot like i kind of like i'm
grateful for
the fact that i grew up like not a
yankees fan or a dodgers fan you know
what i mean like always like used to
winning like i have this kind of
appreciation and like love
for the sport that like sometimes i
don't see in some
in some friends you know and a lot of
like fans who i see like are just like
used to kind of
um winning every year like i like you're
really like
challenged to kind of dig and find like
a love for the sport
and have it not be just fully surrounded
by um
chasing championships you know what i
mean no i know uh and
whenever you had to go to a dark place
uh in the maze runner series or
you know teen wolf on mtv dylan o'brien
i knew that you were just
you you were suffering for your craft
you were suffering for your crap
you could see what was really behind
those eyes exactly you were thinking of
ray lucas you were thinking of which
coach
you were thinking of um i guess uh
what would you say batman sticking
around one inning too long in the world
series against the royals you know
i was there i was there were you there i
was also i was supporting
you know when when when harvey uh uh
charged out you know i was one of the
whatever it was fifty five thousand made
sense it made sense
it really didn't make sense at the time
i know absolutely
absolutely but i do see we we do have a
uh
we did notice you threw out a first
pitch dylan um dylan
talking too late i do believe so um
nothing i've ever done is more
nerve-wracking than throwing out a first
pitch
um i don't know i haven't seen the video
of it but the way you do have
the grip on the baseball it looks like
you're bringing the heat it looks like
you've got like either a split finger or
a four seamer that's coming
how did how did it work out for you that
first pitch
yeah thanks man uh i i'll i'll touch on
two things sure
um uh first of all like it's definitely
the most nerve-wracking thing
i think the only reason that it wasn't
the most
nerve-wracking thing is because there
was about 10 000 people there
uh and it was like a september fifth
game uh where we were out of it you know
so it's like
it was like a good you know it was like
my spring training
um um but uh but still like
just when yeah you just get that one
shot you know it doesn't matter like how
much you
uh uh warm up in the cage you know which
i was getting to do
and i was like i was going into it going
um you know i want to throw this thing
as hard as i can
but that's also such a risk like but
like
you know it's not worth it to you know
like lollygag it in there i
i really wanted to huck it and i did
kind of like
i don't know i like i'm gonna i hope i
hopefully i'm gonna do it again someday
and i'll just like go out there and huck
it but
i did kind of just like hold back a
little bit
um i just when the moment came down and
you know my sneakers on the mound are
really slippery like i couldn't push off
you know i couldn't get my extensions
the sun was in your eyes it's the sun
when you're using your eyes too because
uh you know
i'm with you though i i i i i was so
freaking out because again if you if you
try to throw it too hard you might
hold on to it too long and that's when
you dirt it that's you don't you can't
you don't want that
but yeah i was like yeah i i i was
pretty confident that i could ride it i
knew i wasn't gonna dirty and that's
what everyone's always trying to like
get in your head right um throughout
like you know that's the other thing too
that people don't realize is you're
spending like two hours before the game
walking around
and everyone's just saying to you like
don't
oh my god i'm sorry holy holy oh my god
oh my god i'm sorry
that was the dark place dylan that was
the dark place
that wasn't you know what's so funny
about that too what's so funny about
that is i
just right before this too like my
publicist
gave me a text that was like hey by the
way it'll curse and i was like i was
like all right come on like you know
like you really gotta tell please it's
not your first
rodeo no i know these things happen
still i still did it well
you you just threw a strike uh just like
you did uh with that first pitch dylan
o'brien right here
uh on the rich eyes okay so then let's
get into this um yeah dylan
do you think the jets should tank and
get trevor lawrence
and tell sam darnold you're awesome we
love you so much we have to set you free
like literally this is because the jets
have already done
uh a good part of the hard work at owen
five
and darnold is is banged up and they've
let le'veon bell go which is exactly the
wrong person to let i know that there
might be stuff crazy going on behind the
scenes but
he's talented enough to to maybe help
sam darnold out here a little bit
so what is your two cents on the subject
yeah uh my two cents for as quick as i
possibly can is
um yeah i mean look i like it's not that
i i still
i think i got some faith left and sam
somewhere else
you know um but yeah i think that like
you know we need a whole system reset
you know like none of these guys are
douglas's guys like
you know uh he he hasn't had the chance
to build
the team he wants we have picks we have
cap space
you know i don't think we're going to
see gates obviously last beyond this
year if next week
you know and it's like it's just going
to be a tear down but we've got
uh we've got some things in place you
know i think the jamal move was the
right move i mean look
it's like you know i was it's hilarious
how my cousin chat was like going off
the other day i've got two cousins who
were big giants fans
um and we were like basically like
uh talk competing for like you know
like who was like uh like the worst team
you know to get trevor lawrence yes um
and we're just like
you know you would have thought it was
so funny because we were like bragging
about like how bad
each of our teams were basically like
the opposite it should be like i was
just like i was like you guys don't
understand we got something special this
year
you know that like that number one picks
ours um
but yeah i just think uh i think it'll
be interesting i think if you get the
number one pick
how can you not go with trevor lawrence
right you know uh
you know and but it's all gonna depend
on like you know when the season ends
uh uh like and you know we reset the
system and have a you know we're gonna
get a new head coach and then it's gonna
have to be his guy
as uh well as doug was this guy and you
know so we'll see we'll see if it's
lawrence and then we just build around
that and we
go we got the picks to do it in the cash
space so you know
it's uh again this is how you uh operate
as a jets fan
fan no i know dylan o'brien here on the
rich eisen show and it's also
you know uh it sounds like you're
surrounded by monsters uh
in in a dystopian moment uh all alone
with nobody around
uh dylan and oh my gosh that's actually
what
love and monsters is a is is about would
you not say
dylan yeah man it's true again this is
how i pick my projects you know
we see actually a photograph of a dog on
top of you uh
that that does that does in a way look
like a member of the denver broncos on
top of
uh sam darnold from just a couple of
thursdays ago i'll be very honest with
you yeah
yeah i think like what we don't realize
is sam runs around about
you know 500 yards a game um
if we're just talking laterally and like
in circles you know man i would
so much wish that we just could talk
about the jets being dominant
in the division and you and i could just
be like high-fiving through the phone
right here but that's just not
the way the world so i guess let's talk
about uh this film uh that uh is again
available on premium video on demand and
digital purchase this this friday and
what
you know you have such a rabid fan base
that loves everything you do
dylan your social media is through the
roof um so what can fans expect
from you and of you and from you uh in
this movie
oh man um i guess like
it's really sweet you know it's really
like good-natured movie
which i think like it's kind of uh it's
funny how it unfolded
it's uh coming out now amidst all this i
think it's
you know i think we sort of i know i
have
like i've just sort of like started to
appreciate really like
you know i don't want to like i don't
want to like subvert anything i don't
want to like
be surprised or guest or watch any like
you know
dark things right now like it's actually
kind of nice i've been kind of like
enjoying watching like really like good
natured things lately just like
make me feel good for an hour and a half
you know and just like
see some positivity going on and that's
kind of that's like i think that's
uh i think that's the selling point you
know it's it's just like a really sweet
and cute and really original movie too
you know it's another thing about it
that i was really uh
uh drawn to and um proud to like you
know try to champion that you know
um it's just like the kind of movie that
i don't think we see as much anymore
um a little throwback to like the amblin
kind of
80s sort of like singular narrative type
uh
type thing you know um you're referring
to the spielbergian type of uh
film where you're looking for love and
there's a dog involved and well you're
looking at your high school sweetheart
there's a dog involved there might you
know there are some monsters uh but it's
just uh
a fun movie when it all comes down to it
yeah exactly it's got like a very pixary
energy like it could have very easily
been like a
like a pixar movie okay that we did like
live action for a lot less money you
know what i mean
i do know what you mean at dylan o'brien
on twitter um
and uh greatly appreciate the call and
in the time what are you playing fantasy
as well
there's at least that uh being a better
part of your life football life i'm just
jets or what
it's going great the fantasy is going
great i got two squads this year uh
the boys are eating um i guess the
highlight is metcalf on both teams i
uh he was my guy who i was you and i
look at the boss man
dude i chris brockman my colleague
across the way was drafting in a charity
league that i could not draft he's our
general manager tell him the one player
i said we must come home with
d.k metcalf yes and i've got him in my
other league too oh he's just
he is a delight monster he's a delight
he's a monster he's such a monster
uh yeah so that's uh that's been the i
feel like it always surrounds like one
pick if you can like really like
hit on that guy like a little lower i
mean i reached for him a bit you know
but like
he's just been pumping so it's great
he's amazing so when you say the boys
are written is that the name of the
fantasy team or that you're just
describing how well your team is doing
oh what the
what was it what was that i said no you
said the boys are eating
and i'm wondering if that was not my
name no no no no no no no i can't my
names are far too inappropriate to say
are you serious like your publicist
would not want you to say your name then
your team names
oh man she's probably texting me right
now um
um no but uh no like they're eating like
they're eating uh
like you know uh points every week maybe
a lot of points they're eating w's
just like jameis winston did back in the
day you got to eat it oh man i really
oh i don't like that i really did not
like that
when he was eating w's back then uh yeah
i wasn't a fan
oh buddy uh okay anybody that we know
that's in your lead
you want to drop any names anybody or
just buddies or yours friends of yours
no buddies yeah just buddies of mine
okay just a regular guy
dylan o'brien from new york um okay bud
thanks for the call let's do this again
uh let's not go several years in between
um and good luck on your fantasy
let's do it let's do it let's do it more
often you take care of yourself dylan
pleasure with you too right back that's
dylan o'brien at dylan o'brien
on twitter is he on instagram tour is he
not on uh is he on the ground
there's a fan there's nobody right now
there's 1.3 million for the fact
and it's a fan account i mean fans run
that account so
uh to the people who run that account
and
uh people who are tuned in right now
because dylan o'brien appeared on the
rich eisen show
it's at rich eisenhower